on the mount for the angels 29-year-old
left-hander andrew heaney looking to get
it back on track after taking a loss
friday in seattle last year's alcs mvp a
non-starter yesterday for the raise in
their win and he gets him on three
pitches fast faster and fastest fastball
upstairs
baldwin two strikes to count to emanuel
margot
couldn't hold up back to back strikeouts
for heeney to start the game so this
will be the ninth pitch of this at-bat
and here it comes he got him chased the
high fastball threw it by him struck him
out and that's how the inning will end
tonight the tampa bay rays going with
the opener once again colin mchugh will
get the open his
fifth game of the season first start
kevin cash
trying to oversee a
uh you know a series sweep here oh look
at that man how about that
got him to chase
he is flat-footed and just reaching
reaching and just a hacking at that
baseball it's not really even a swing
and a foul
tipped strikeout right back into the mid
and a cut in the miss the chase from
trout
the next 3-2 from heeney
got him looking
all seven outs in the game via the
strikeout
here's the next delivery and he will
it's chased and missed the fastball was
outside struck him out
so haney with five strikeouts already
2-2
wow
austin meadows will be the next batter
next delivery and that's a good breaking
ball chased and missed and meadows is
down on strikes still a pretty
impressive record so far for phlegm
as he comes in with a record of one and
three with a two era 2.18 to be exact
he's still a rookie swinging a ground
ball left side diving his wendell to his
left he gets up and throws him out one
away
so one out of runner at second and the
batter now will be phil gosling who's
playing third base and hitting out of
the nine hole
right-handed batter against the lefty
reliever of the pitch grounded sharply
it's a fair ball and that is going to
drive in the game's first run lagaris
will score easily goslin will go to
second make the turn and he'll hold
their
back to back one out doubles gosling's
first rbi is an angel it's one nothing
halos
fletcher an excellent contact hitter
he pitches up and it's lined into left
one hop rotor's going to try to score
and a good throw should get him he is
out at the plate
fletcher
with a base hit into left rose arena
charging it
and gosselin is cut down trying to score
shohei will be ready on the first pitch
one of the five strikeout victims for
mccue
in the first two innings tonight
and on the first pitch a big ball out to
right center field and that one ain't
coming back
a no doubter that one well over 400 feet
that is ohtani's 10th home run this
season
and that is a two run shot three nothing
angels
[Applause]
the batter will be zenino
heaney is ready looking for the final
out and he gets it right there a swing
and a miss another fastball threw it by
him struck him out on three pitches
a pair of strikeouts in the inning and
already nine in the game for hiney out
of the first 12 outs
here's a rose arena batting now their
leadoff man
max stassi
went on the concussion list and on the
two strike delivery to
a rosarina he will take that pitch and
that's in there a breaking ball freezes
him he's a strikeout victim for the
second time tonight and that is now 10
already in the game for
haney out of the first 15 outs
legarra stumbled and scored one of the
three runs
for the angels in the third second time
that fleming is seeing him
deal one here's a swinging grounder back
up toward the middle diving stopped by
adamus he gets up from behind second and
throws the first in time
and yandi was able to keep his foot on
the bag to take care of the garage
moving to second on the play of suzuki
in another five play
defensively for the rays
two balls two strikes
the pitch swing and a miss he got him to
chase again away and that seems to be an
area that can fluster fletcher
and that will retire the side so fleming
works around the lead off base hit we're
through five this is mike zanino at the
plate
there's a high shot back into deep left
lagarus will turn around and watch it
sail that baby's gone
home run for mike cenino
and the rays are on the board making it
3-1
home run number six on the year for
cenino three to one angels
and randy rosarina the batter with
phillips at first he's not going and
randy swings and tries one to the gap in
right center giving chase his ward and
it's between he and trout and goes all
the way to the wall phillips to third
base he is being waived heading for the
plate here's the throw the tag he is
safe at home it's an rbi double for a
rosarena and the rays have drawn to
within one 3-2 angels
here's manuel margot the rosarito fast
runner at second margot not bunning and
he swings in grounds one inside first
down the right field line ward over to
get it rory serena around third loses
his helmet and comes home to score the
tying run it's three to three in the
eighth
and the batter yandy diaz nobody on
margot second meadows it first in the
eighth in a 3-3 tie the pitch runners go
and it's off the mid of the catcher
suzuki and heading for the plate margot
the throw the tag by sluggers he's safe
at home and the rays take a 4-3 lead
all the way to third goes meadows
the pitch to diaz on 3-0 chop towards
short off the glove of the
jumping iglesias and out on the left it
brings home meadows and a 5-3 raised
lead
all right well it's first and third only
one out and here's zanino
that's a hot shot
a base hit that will get diaz home from
third
zanito drives in a run
so the rays continue to add on
now the tenth man to come up this inning
started with brett phillips
three for seven with runners
in scoring position phillips swings and
sends one in the air towards right
towards the corner giving chase ward and
this one gets down for a base hit
wendell scores zenino third being waved
the throw to the plate is on the way
incenino slides in safely it's a two-run
double for brett phillips and the rays
have blown it open
it is 8-3
in the eighth
12th batter up in the inning here's the
next pitch he pops this one up this
should
mercifully end the inning and under
making the grab on that one will be
david fletcher in shallow right field
hop out to the second baseman and that
will end the inning
and here's taylor ward
reid's next one swung on and grounded
right side yoshi diving stop gets up
flips the reed covering and he got the
foot on the bag just in time and the
rays win